hey guys my name is just today it is the
22nd of june and he is the important
things that have been happening in video
gaming The Last Guardian may have been
in development for nine years now but
Sony have said the game will live up to
the expectations it's built up over that
time Sony boss Shuhei Yoshida told games
well I'm not worried I have confidence
in the team and away two sons vision we
are so excited to finally be able to
play this game that needed to be out
when asked whether the publisher had
ever considered canceling the Last
Guardian throughout its problematic
development cycle Yashida replied that
the game has always been in development
adding it took longer especially when we
made the decision to move from ps3 to
ps4 a lot of the engineering effort had
to be redone from scratch so that
contributed to the length of the project
The Last Guardian will be released on
October 25 The Legend of Zelda breath of
the wild producer Adrian uma has
explained why the upcoming game is going
to feature voice acting for the first
time in the series the numa told polygon
it's really difficult to leave an
impression on players with just tax it's
not that I made everything voice but I
have these moments where I want to leave
impressions on users I add voice there
that being said our protagonist link
will still not be voiced in the upcoming
game which innumerous says is because if
link says something the user doesn't
agree with that relationship between the
user and link would be lost rather the
wild is due to release on Wii U and an
ex in 2017 finally PlayStation worldwide
studios boss Shuhei Yoshida has said
that the upcoming more powerful
playstation 4 neo will not shorten the
life cycle of the ps4 when asked if
console generations were getting shorter
as a result of Sonia marks after
releasing hardware upgrades your shooter
applied well no ps4s ps4 you know the
new high-end ps4 is still ps4 so you
know the life cycle is not going to be
shorter these comments align with those
of PlayStation president and your house
earlier this month who said that the neo
is intended to fit
inside and complement the standard ps4 a
report has suggested that the Neo will
arrive this year although Sony have not
revealed any official launch date for
the console as yet xboxes project
Scorpio is scheduled to arrive in
holiday 2017 let me know down in that
comment box if you're keen on getting a
higher powered console and be sure to
stop by game [ __ ] where we've got
stories on the gameplay of watch dogs
too and the uncharted movie that is
everything I have you today but you join
me again tomorrow for a bunch more news